okay hi everyone we are meeting to talk
about the compiler
here and christopher
is in charge and
where do we start
well i think this is where we left off
so so i mean there's basically there's
the stuff that we skimmed over last time
and then there's actually like two more
additional things
um
but i'm pretty sure this is where we
started skimming
so
uh
right
so basically what this is um
what the the interface function stuff is
is basically uh
uh
when you where it's basically for having
certain callbacks for things like when
the reference count turns to zero and
stuff like that kind of low level things
where they're we don't want to have an
actual
function
you know that that because you'd never
want to call it yourself where you'd
still like to provide like run this code
when this happens
uh hold on a second so this is this is
who is going to be running code who is
taking the call back is it an external c
program or what is it
well depends on what it is but i mean
i'd say that most of the time it's
so
i mean fundamentally it's the the
compiler itself is going to our code
yeah our code so can you give me an
example of what well they're on free
thing as an example so
right so this i mean well there served
some different ones here so so on freeze
one where i mean this would be like when
the reference count turns to zero if you
have some big data structure maybe one
that's you you know from some library
and you need to call some library
function to free it that's where you do
that but but that that's a kind of a
library example there's some that are
involved no libraries so for example
these
two from expression things which maybe
you could have different names these are
basically like
um
you know so if you use compile
expression declaration it automatically
knows how to convert between data you
know its data structures and expressions
but if you just use a type declaration
you define a struct or something it has
no idea how to convert that to and from
an expression so you need to give it
basic functions where you tell it you
know this is the function for converting
this data structure to an expression
here's the one for the other direction
and so on but you know
we don't
the other option would be to have a
function that's like you know the from
expression function it's like a symbol
from expression and and you call and and
you know you just add a declaration to
that symbol and then and then it will
know what to do the problem is you never
want to call it yourself
when you declare the struct
okay
are you are you in a position to give
the from and to expression
things upon declaration what is this
world expression
declaration dude
well kind of i mean
so the answer fundamentally is not
really to to about about providing the
functions there i mean so being compiled
expression declaration you don't provide
the function it figures out what the
function should be because it's sort of
a restricted case
um
i think that you couldn't just provide
the function though because these can be
sort of polymorphic and complicated ways
where you do something like oh here's
the uh here's the unboxing function for
packed arrays of integers and here's the
unboxing function for packed arrays of
reals and you know etc etc
um
so it can be more complicated than that
right
okay
so
okay but but but
um what am i thinking here so wait a
second so what happens if you've given
if you set up a struct
and you don't give the from expression
and then the from expression is needed
it will fail it just won't compile
oh
inside the compiler what it won't do is
it won't come
it won't come from the evaluator into
the compiler or go
out of the compiler in back to the
evaluator
so right like you couldn't
you couldn't return this struct from a
function without a compiled code
function
you could return it from a function
um to another compiled function you just
couldn't return it to the evaluator
right
um and converting these things into and
out of the evaluator is super powerful
because it makes you inter-operate with
you know sort of evaluated code i mean
it's incredibly powerful okay so hold on
a second but that means that
okay so what does it look like so you
declare a struct how do you declare the
struct
so that would be with type declaration
which i don't think i have an example
actually i might have an example up here
although although we changed these to be
associations but yeah
something like this
okay
so why is it that you don't give
the
these um interface functions
along with the actual type declaration
okay so you could take this case
suppose it's right suppose it's
polymorphic you know it can take you
know a field you know this can be any
type or something like that
and now i have two different
i have two different conversion
functions one for the case where this t
is an integer and one for this case
where the t is you know a real you know
something else you know whatever right
that's really easy to do like this
because it's sort of like well i'm just
going to
i'm just going to compile like
one version of this write a couple of
types for it um christopher yeah i mean
i you know you could do something like
you know typed
like i could just say something like
uh
foo of um you know integer 64 or
something like that
did we settle on the new syntax instead
of that foo
we had that nice syntax with columns
we did yeah yeah okay
um
right so i mean you'd have something
like like this and that would handle the
integer case and then if i had a
different real
case i'd i'd you know you can do that
what the hell does this do i don't
understand doesn't it you have to give
it code
yeah yeah
yes which would you you know
how does that wait a minute what the
heck does that mean what is this the
type this is the this is the headdress
or the headdress this is the the sort of
operator form of type
hold on hold on what does that mean so
you can say
typed of a function and that's
equivalent to putting function of
like a typed lambda
function of typed x is that correct yeah
except it's giving the output type
right so so small yeah
right so first first of all these are
the same thing
um i didn't say so far that's nice
that's cool
yeah yeah which is which lets you put
the type at the beginning which is kind
of nicer than having it at the end and
so on but you're doing the type on the
function you see that's that's no it's
nice because it also allows you to take
a function that was just a naked
evaluator level function and typify it
yep absolutely
how do you do multi-argument it's just a
list
yeah it's a list but how does that work
oh it's just a list there inside the
type declaration
right
this is how you write the type of a
function is you have a list of the
argument types and then you have the
return type
so can you just show me inside a
function how that works because the
function usually would have multiple it
would say function of list x
function declaration yeah yeah right
yeah i mean you say let me do this with
a different um
uh i think differently so i'd say you
know foo and it's going to say right
okay so there's two ways of doing it you
can either do function of
uh you know type uh typed
a log one okay
or can you do a function of typed
argument too
you may have the r1 and r2 inside of the
typed yes because that would be the
analog of that uh operator
well it's not quite because
because it says so the arguments so the
point is that
this is the type of this whole function
right right so that makes sense to have
that this is the type of this argument
it makes sense to have that how does it
get a list
yeah i get it doesn't in this case it
infers the return type yeah
if it can
right but if you wanted to give the
return type inside the function couldn't
you do that by having a syntax that's a
reform function we don't have a syntax
for that well at the same time
right so the way you do that right now
would be
um you'd sort of make it very easy for
her to do the inference by basically
just you know writing something like you
know like this right so the return value
is wrapped in a typed
right and then it's like yeah and then
you can you can obviously
you're forcing it to figure out what it
is i mean we could maybe have a syntax
like like this or something
why not just have the syntax where you
can take the operator form and stick it
inside as the first argument
in other words function of because it
doesn't have the type name
parameters right no but but why not why
not just do this why not just take the
thing that is right now in the operator
form of typed
and just hit make another one make
another one make another it's awkward
stephen because of evaluation remember
function is hold off
wait you're going to say something like
this no no get rid of the typed inside
just just the just the type
specification
whatever the type specification was
there yes
where where are the arguments where are
the arguments
hold on hold on hold on hold on
i see
so that's the signature
i see well maybe maybe there needs to be
a form like the argument names arrow and
then that typed thing right something
well that's kind of what i was saying
you could have some exotic thing like
this
yeah you've got that written down there
we we could have something like that it
seems a bit weird that um
well it's also all right i think to wrap
the
if you could could you also wrap the
whole function
outside and typed rather than the
operator form you could just that's the
same thing yes i mean these are these
are equivalent so yes you can just say
typed of
you know
this comma this yeah
that works too okay and by the way the
foo in this case that is simply the
struct name right so the foo has nothing
to do with the function yeah yeah that
is correct that's the type of the first
argument
okay
and so am i right in believing that that
in the case where you have typed
arguments they always have to be named
as well there's no hash
there's no nameless
it doesn't make any sense i don't think
it makes any sense
uh hold on let me just see so
sorry in the in the in the headdress
wrapper
not headdress in the operator form
you're not naming you're simply giving a
type signature so in that case you could
in fact have
uh anonymous names you could oh you
could you could
that's very nice that you can just give
the type signature
and apply it to the function
okay is it slightly outside of the
function you see it's like metadata or
something that we're well yes
but so how does that apply to
down value
assignments and things is there an
analogous thing you can do there
how do you imagine specifying the types
so what i've implemented which is not a
final thing for the down values is you
you make a function declaration you just
say this function
go and use the down here's the type and
use the down values for it so it's not
really
you know a polished thing so we we don't
have a way of attaching types to down
values okay but hold on let's think
about this for a second so you've got
some function f
and i mean long long ago i mean it's
still used in the system
the the whole mechanism of uh
the way install works and the way that
it creates an a
a compiled code call whatever it's
called
what is it called i thought something
something external call or something
that is
a piece of the down value list when
you've done an install is that correct
no that's long since there's no trace of
that in in the evaluator
there's only down code the only
you know
internal code you can call is down code
no no i'm saying if you use install
right it installs
through down values it installs some
down values that get called yes i i know
that but but
i know that
but
okay sets up definitions that send call
packet objects to the external program
it does that with down values yeah so i
know that but i'm i'm saying
it adds
a
a down value which i think is what
should be being done with the compiler
as well but it adds a compiled down
value or you you have a mechanism no you
don't catch down code i mean i just add
down code to the symbol right i mean
there's no syntax for this right now
though right i mean there's an integer
there is there's an internal syntax for
it but right there's
the down code is run after
down values yeah and so if you've got
super efficient down code for one case
and you want to fall through to down
values how do you do it
well if it's just one case i mean if
it's all the so i have a thing that
compiles all of the down values i know
but let's say you can't be faster right
yes i i know i know but so are you
saying that in the case okay so you've
got a bunch of down values you try and
do a compilation certain cases which you
specify with types
are compilable other cases are not so
they need to fall through to the down
value code how is that supposed to work
well then you would probably have to
have the um
you know it would depend whether they're
overlapping or not i mean if they were
all sort of overlapping you'd have to
leave the down values and just i know
that but no it's just in case the case
is something like you know you have mean
and mean has you know its own well me is
made pretend mean is implemented in the
top level you know mean has its own
definitions but when you apply a mean to
a bunch of around objects you'd like it
to use this compiled code function
right
yeah that that's basically the use case
right but of course mean works on
anything right and so you know it's it's
it's not like there's going to be a hole
in the patterns so i mean one option
would be to change the down values so
that you know oh there's just a hole in
the patterns where it checks that oh by
the way
you know your your argument isn't just a
list of a bunch of nice arounds
um but of course that's a little bit
painful
um another alternative which is maybe
also not great would be that you just
add a down value to mean that that's
sort of like uh you know when mean is
applied to a list of you know arounds
then call yeah you know internal mean
and internal mean is
is this down value compiled thing
although that kind of
sort of gets
the point of having down code
okay let's look look let's look okay
right now with install what it is doing
is that mechanism that is it is
installing down values which point to
external code right so what does install
do if you if you if you basically try
and overwrite existing function
it'll stick its
front it depends whether whether the
existing function has down values or not
actually no no no but it's going to
stick its thing in front of the existing
function
it's going to start never behind i
believe it's in front but i'm not sure
of but i mean it's still it's not
satisfying
it doesn't do what tom's code is doing
which is to have a super efficient down
code call
right so it's just it's still going
through the evaluator so the question
really is
what do we what we need is a sandwich of
some kind where
if you say
here is a type declaration and this is
the case where i can call
newly installed down code
what i really want is a sandwich where
there's user down code
user down values system down code
isn't that
correct in other words we need a new
hook
that can take user down code and put it
in front of user down values am i
correct
it's just the idea that basically
uh
that that that it'll always try and use
the down code for running you know the
optimized version of mean that works on
a rounds and only if that fails then it
will go to the down values that's right
because because right now
we are that would be hang on can i show
you what i've done because i think we're
a little bit in the dark okay here okay
fine go ahead right and you know if we
just want it to be that would be very
easy because we just have a fall through
case that goes back to the down values
you see
um
yeah someone needs to stop i can't share
right right
right fine so this is
right so so here are some down values
and i could this is what i implemented
so it's not so this you you would do
function declaration you give it a type
and you say use the down values and then
i can compile it
and then you know i can get
hold on hold on let me just understand
the syntax even vaguely
okay this is the function it's just
compiling it in place
attaching down values and you can
and there's no mixture of down values
and down the code right which is not
going to cut it it's not going to cut it
hold on hold on but it's it's a good
start to this so this is basically from
these down values it generates this
function here which it can compile
and not only that it it you know it's
not going to fail compiling this because
now these could in fact also be caused
to the evaluator as well
so they they okay fine so so what your
so your idea here is not only that this
is going to in line everything will be
massive no i i understand i understand
but i'm trying to understand what you're
doing so what you've got is a
preprocessor that goes from
uh
down values to a function
and then it compiles that function
right
um
so hold on and presumably there could be
some sort of you know fall through of if
you can't compile that usage that's just
going to call the evaluator
at the moment they're right there has to
be a fall through a catch-all you know
advance okay let me let me just
understand this for a second what you're
doing is wait wait one function
you know this is a nanosecond processor
so you know
right okay this is gonna happen
hold on hold on
hold on
hold on hold on what you've got here is
a more generally useful function because
what you're doing is
what you're saying is you've got down
values
you're turning the down values into a
lambda basically correct exactly
okay so that's a general thing of some
utility that's a lambda that represents
the sequence of patterns
hold on hold on hold on
it's not you're right it's not all
patterns so one of the issues is
you're going to do that and it's going
to eat some patterns and some patterns
what's it going to do with until we have
pattern compilation
right so let's imagine that we had a
function let's imagine that your
definition was f of g of x blank colon
equals whatever
right um f
of g of x blank
no g of x g of x plane g of x blank
right there right like that right right
yeah okay
your pattern your compiler will only
take naked variables there well no hold
on no no no not quite because my
compiler is taking
type and giving a type to it now if i
wanted to compile this i could say
something like i mean you know no
question no no that that i think they
won't be able to access the x is the
point
no no like it won't be able to
automatically i mean it's not not not i
haven't implemented it but it could
access the x because if it knows that
this is expression it would know how to
bind
this against x and actually this one we
could probably optimize that but what
i think is not going in the right
direction okay so one thing you could do
is you could make g of x blank be a type
and you could do everything with types
that's that's what i was saying here you
see right if you locate it but i think
there's an alternative to do that yes i
i know but i think there's an
alternative which is to think of
factoring this operation into two pieces
one is
the unrolling of down value assignments
into lambdas
and the other
is essentially having a procedural
pattern matching step
i think and i'm not quite seeing how to
do that
the pattern matching step is procedural
because the pattern matcher tries you
know rules in in order i know but i know
but that's not the point i'm making the
point i'm making is do you mean that is
run time pattern matching in compiled
code that's what i'm saying yes yeah
because we we can compile patterns yeah
yeah we we've got code to do that
okay but so hold on let me understand so
the first thing which is an interesting
thing that you're demonstrating is
taking
variables whose types you know or or
arguments whose types you understand
and creating
let me look at the lander you created
for that test fund thing
this thing see how does that work how
does it do the different cases how does
it do the most
okay all right okay
um
you know it could do something else
cleverer because oh you have to look at
like
you know this this is helpful to look at
because you know the down values right
i'm using them in the order in which the
down values which obviously is the right
thing but we could do cleverer things
like like this and this we could we
could like do that okay you can optimize
separately like hash table dispatching
over literals which the current pattern
match doesn't do so if you had like a
million of these yes
sequentially people that write alpha
discover this and then they have to go
and rewrite their patterns excuse me it
doesn't do that it doesn't do that the
down value it absolutely does not do
that you know that is optimized
it does do that i've checked this very
carefully okay it doesn't if it does
that somebody ripped out code that's
been there
i'm talking about
individual you see like in in one inside
one pattern that does that but not not
from you know different values it's just
nonsense i mean if i say f of
one f of two f of three f of whatever
that is absolutely a hash dispatch
right right absolutely that but that's
not what we have here we have x blank so
if you had f of x comma one f of x right
comma two you're absolutely right you're
right you're right but that's an
important case and alpha people discover
that you know okay okay
okay tom
we can do that i understand i understand
so what you've got is you're thinking of
the down values list
and you are compiling that into in a
very wicked kind of way into a witch
right
yes
okay so now let's try to understand
if the arguments inside there
were instead of that being test fund of
x blank y blank it's test flowing of g
of x blank doesn't look hopeless to
compile that no no it's not hopeless at
all absolutely i utterly agree it's
right so
i just didn't do that okay hold on hold
on so what you would turn that into is a
witch in which there are match cues
instead of minus one absolutely whatever
yes
yes
i mean that that's ultimately what has
to happen once i mean the issue is that
right now
you can compile some patterns but also
it takes it you know it's like very it
takes a million years to compile
something and so it's not super
practical
uh okay but so
but for things like startup code we we
could do this and you could make a
compiler just
technology like this
so okay there's also the case of of what
what do you do when the function has
different you know if there's different
usages that for example take different
numbers of arguments or just yeah well
that's why that doesn't happen in this
thing here because i gave a type to it
and so it just picks up the ones that
have two arguments
okay but in the morning we know which
ones it can work it has to work okay and
i mean it doesn't even have to be you
know you could have two arguments but
one of them could take integers and one
of them could take expressions and one
of them could take absolutely
this this could be extended in many ways
so so what i was wanting to use it for
this was astonishingly useful okay
absolutely
okay so for example if there are uh
double blanks and things like that
yeah what you would have to have here
is i mean i don't quite know how that
works in terms of the function what is
the the named argument
version of hash
in a function
there isn't one so okay so we'll have to
invent one yes
okay
so but that's going to be okay hold on
here so
we're sorry i mean you can't just bind
it to an expression that contains a
sequence or something yeah well that's
what it would be um
yes possibly okay okay but so then what
you're showing here
is something that has proceduralized the
assignments
which then gives you a fighting chance
of just using traditional compiler
technology to compile the whole thing
which is great
which by the way though i mean i think i
think
if you could really compile patterns
then the which statement would basically
just be you know
does this match the first pattern if so
called the first you know definition
just well actually
it could be
well
more generally the point is is that i
think it turns into
you know kind of a map thread kind of
thing you know it's it's uh
right i mean i think that the the
ability to convert the patterns to a
which statement is kind of just a result
of the fact that we can't really compile
patterns efficiently right now
well there's particular sorts of
patterns where you know the match queue
has evaporated into
things
but you want to look at that
we have pretty much the full pattern
language compilable it's it's
now the implementation is fairly naive
and it isn't quite as fast
as
the kernels because
because i wrote it and it's naive but
right other than some corner cases and a
few things
you you have almost everything you want
um
so what you're saying andrew is that
that if
the original declaration the compiler
environment append to contained
expression types there
that
then the actual down value list
which includes would could be compilable
is that right
yeah i mean you could you can turn those
expressions into compiled expressions
you can compile them and you can match
against them so you can do these things
i think i think i think that's true yes
so sorry
i'll take out that i think that is true
yes we we could do quite a lot if they
were expressions right okay so oh the
right and the right hand side could call
the evaluator i mean this would be
correct there'd be no
you know not working or working because
we would know what was okay so what
you're what you're claiming here
is that my claim about sandwiches is
unnecessary that your claim is that
given a down values list
that
you could use this technology to turn it
into a pure piece of compiled code
even though that compiled code might
have to contain evaluator callbacks for
some of the data yeah
correct that's true right i think this
is true basically just that the function
dispatch should be written in the
compile will be compiled which is great
that's fine so just to understand here
like that witch or the switch
one could well imagine that there are
all kinds of optimizations even from
brilliant function types of things
there's endless these these are like
fantastic absolutely absolutely yes yes
yes
okay but so so just to understand the
status here so we could actually make
something you're saying that would take
any down value list
and
i just want to understand what the
syntax is going to look like so it would
take any f
and it would allow you
what would it actually look like okay
compile down values isn't it down below
i i don't know that's the right i'm just
i thought downloads didn't have a
capital b am i wrong
uh down values has a capital
v oh sorry okay
that just looks blue so it looks wrong
because it looks blue because it doesn't
have a color yeah no i know i know i
know notice here's another weird thing
when i when i did this
okay
it it when i did function compile it
clears the down values so so it just
goes straight to the down code so it
lost the coloring
oh that's a bug which has to be fixed
well well fine that's that's yes yeah a
missing feature yeah yeah absolutely yes
oh yeah but actually it isn't a missing
what you've done here i i just want to
understand how this works
you have taken
a okay down value processing now if i do
this if i do this now
it's uh
oh what have i done oh i think i've
i don't know what i've done
uh
can we please just walk through the
workflow of this oh i know what i've
done right i've made a compile i need
there's another thing that you need
which is you need to install
i haven't installed this as down code
for test fun so that this this is a bug
actually okay okay hold on hold on hold
on hold on
okay so you've got one piece of
functionality that takes a an f of blank
you know pattern type thing and wraps it
all up into a lambda basically
and then compiles that right now wait a
second wait a second wait a second
there's one piece of functionality that
will take an f of x blank blah blah blah
blah blah and turn it into a pure
function right that's one piece of
functionality has nothing to do with the
compiler yes although i would argue that
again if you have if you have a fully
functioning pattern matcher than that
that that operation is pretty trivial i
mean here it's using which which makes
it less trivial
but if you add
all the patterns and it was cheap to
complete so on then that would be
pretty still syntactically non-trivial
because you've you've made assignments f
of x blank blah blah blah blah blah
it's syntactically non-trivial to do the
rapping i mean
you know occasionally i do it of taking
a
you know an f of x blank blah blah
and turning it into a pure function but
it's a pain to do that
yeah am i making sense i mean it's just
syntactically
you know those are two different
branches of how one thing yeah it's a
new system right right
right so there's a there's value
to being able to take
that and just have a function
that goes from down values
and i i'm not even going to ask about
sub values yet
but i think we should be thinking ahead
to sub values
have you thought about sub values
well i mean
you know some values in a sense don't
really exist but you're not gonna like
answer
but they're just extra arguments in in
you know the magic yes that may be but
okay so
okay but
what you
okay so one thing one could imagine
is something that simply takes any list
of rules
represented by down values
and turns that list of rules yeah yeah
here's the point you want a function
that's called something like
uh replacements to function
that's a bad name
do you understand what i'm saying so so
you can take that list of down values or
for that matter any list of pattern
matching rules
and turn that list of pattern matching
rules
into now there's a trickiness that's
otherwise known as there is a there's an
existing function for that it's called
replace
no but i understand that this would be
the equivalent of replace
but it would be something which can
explicitly take this
but you see there's a trickiness here
because you've got that thing called
test fund in the middle of this
the only difference between this you
know that conversion to this function or
replace is just the fact that you know
this is this is
sort of right you know writing out a
procedural program to do it as opposed
to just doing it
yes i agree i agree but there's a value
to having that procedural program which
you can then do things with i mean i'm
but but as i'm saying it isn't quite the
same thing because inside that
down value list there is a test fund
hold pattern of test fund blah blah blah
yes
right whereas
so in other words in a sense the name of
this is test fun you see that's right so
let's just understand what this would be
so what you're saying is you're taking
that list there and what you're saying
is make a function
which is the equivalent it's like
solving an equation
given this list of rules
apply you know let's say you said
replace of all of that
okay so they're just you know you're out
18. just take out 18 and just type
replace of all of that just copy out 18.
copy that and type replace of all of
that
okay and replace what right no no
no no no no no no no no don't replace
anything just close the bracket at the
end okay it's a okay so now that form
now apply that to test fun
of um you know one minus
minus one three
okay there might be some issues with
holding but yeah no it worked okay well
you might have evaluated the test fund
but yeah i mean okay fundamentally that
does work
okay so now what we're saying is what
i'm saying is
what you want
and this is it's sort of solving an
equation
that takes yes so that that
is applied to minus one three not to
test fund one three okay
yeah so we'll get the same answer yes i
i know i know so my point is
there's an operation here which is
taking that thing
with the function embedded inside the
list
i don't quite understand how this should
work
i'm i'm looking for a function okay and
then what you've got to do at the end of
this you've got to reinstall so you've
got these three things that you can do
you've got replace
with the explicit function in there
you've got the pure function which just
goes inside the test fund to take its
arguments to steal its arguments away
and do the evaluation okay
then you've got case number three which
is you want to write back and to test
fund
that
direct
steal my arguments and evaluate thing
see what i'm saying right so that's test
fund equals that function effectively
well let's call it test yes right that's
what it is that's what it is that's
that's that's what it is now now
okay so hold on hold on yes so that
should just work now okay great
okay so now what i'm trying to
understand is
you've got
okay
the first step is
to take
your set of assignments because what i'm
worried about is this okay
it's not going to work to just okay so
you've you've got a notebook or a you
know a file that has a bunch of f of x
blank blah blah blahs in it
okay
then you compile
then you change one of those f of x
blank blah blah blah yeah yeah right
well that's that's absolutely yes
right
so
let's just understand what what we want
this to look like in the end do we want
it to be the case
that you make those assignments
and then see this is sort of a meta
assignment
that you're making
in the end right you have a meta
assignment which is actually cl take all
those assignments and repackage them as
a compiled object
okay so do we have any analogy for meta
assignments it's a little bit like
attributes isn't it
except that attributes we have the
the kind of the the
sort of the lazy rule that you have to
set attributes before you start making
assignments
do you see what i'm saying
in other words
i didn't know that
you can i thought you could make
assignments and then set an attribute
nope i don't think so i mean maybe
somebody fixed that in the interview in
30 years but
i believe that the pattern compiler
if you post set the attribute the
pattern compiler does not know
for things like one identity and flat
yes that's true right
non-patent matching attributes that's
yes that's right but i mean the fact is
that the
this is exactly the same situation right
that is that the the um
but this one you want to do it at the
end
yes that's that's what that's the point
i'm making so but you want to do it at
the end but when is the end because you
might go back and re re you know and
edit the code right so maybe the thing
maybe the thing is it should you know it
should somewhere keep the down values
and and basically if you if you add
another one it's going to recompile or
something yeah okay so then
let me suggest perhaps perhaps the right
thing to do is to treat it like an
attribute that says every time there's
an assignment here see that's a bit
funky i mean one thing you could do is
say
set an attribute that says every time
there's an assignment
do a compilation
you could get it to just compile the new
assignment i would call it auto compile
i would call it auto compile okay
auto compile i mean i i think yeah yeah
yeah i'm
okay okay all right but so so then
that would what that would do
uh i see but you're saying christopher
the new ones but i don't understand how
you graph the new ones onto the old ones
well i think i think the i mean one way
you could do it is just that each down
value is compiled separately and then
you compile this one pretty small
dispatch function that you know
calls out to them and then you know when
you add a new definition you need to
compile the new definition and then you
need to recompile the dispatch function
but hopefully that doesn't take very
long
i have a feeling that you don't have
enough control with this i have a
feeling
the um because you might reorder adding
a definition might reorder the down
values so
i have a feeling this is not enough
flexibility i have a feeling that
instead it should be more like
a you know one of your type declaration
type things for test fun because i think
you're going to need a bunch of options
you're going to need all kinds of type
information i tend to agree with that
so so then the alternative which maybe
was what you were going to anyway tom
was some declarative thing about test
fund is that what you had up that's kind
of what this is actually so
that's what this is and this was
sufficient for what i wanted to do okay
all right well i think that's that i
think i think it should not be inside of
something like compiler environment to
pen two or functional pile because
because
i mean those are for modifying compiler
environments not free but it has
modified that means if i write another
function if i do this
well i'm sure yeah sure you can use test
function right right but i mean
but it's also absolutely correct sorry
no no but it's also changing the
behavior of stuff in the evaluator which
compiler environment no no this hasn't
changed the evaluator this in itself
needs to it's not changed there's that's
not the point one needs to change the
evaluator right absolutely that's what i
think
okay so i think what i think
is something like set compiled
you know set auto compile or something
yeah just write that down just just
something like set auto compile
um
of test fun
and that with a bunch of random you know
parameters there
right type signatures and things yeah
yeah yeah right and so then what you
would do
is if you say set auto compile
and then you give a bunch of definitions
it would have potentially heuristics to
decide when to actually do the
compilation
so you put the definitions in here no no
you no no not at all not at all you've
got the definitions the definitions are
things that you have developed
over the course of millions of years
you know in
pure evaluated code right and then you
say oh i think i know what i'm doing now
or it's not running fast enough let me
set auto compile on this function
right so the zeroth thing is probably if
you just say set or compile of test fun
the next one would be if you give it a
type
exactly yeah
yes set auto compile of test fund it
will try and do its best doing
essentially expression compilation
and um okay and then what happens is and
then then presumably there's a clear
auto compile
yeah now the question is what does it
look like no it's right what does it
look like after you've set auto compile
if you
i suspect what should happen is if
you've set auto compile and you ask for
down values of test fund
that what you should see
is the first argument the first entry
and down values of test fund should be
some weird compiler call thing
yeah except it's not really a down value
i mean
i know it's not a down value but you
have to store the information somewhere
right the down values have become
vestigial at this point because set auto
compiler has trumped them so to speak
yes yes yes right but so
so what would you want to see in the
down values well i'm saying that i think
that for example when you say clear auto
compile
okay so first of all the down values
will continue getting updated if you
reset test fun if you set new values in
test fund the down values would continue
being updated along with whatever auto
compilation has to be done for the first
you know for its auto compile right
right right so that means when you say
clear auto compile all it does
is to throw out that first
special hook
in
the um
i mean internally that's probably not
what it does but no physically wouldn't
do what it does but so then this would
restore it back to the state it was in
so right so what i'm suggesting is that
the first entry in the down values list
would be
something that says
uh
you know something like blank
can you type one just take your down
values listen
okay right
right okay we've got okay all right so
now what i'm saying is
that the first entry should be
you know blank arrow
or something blank colon greater than
uh
yes basically
right
i mean it might need some additional
decoration but that's what i'm basically
suggesting
and that then
usually
yeah yes okay except obviously that's
not really being run there might we
might find problems with this like
people are hacking down value lists and
relying on them well okay so the
question is how do you maintain
okay so here's an alternative okay
actually it's a this is a better idea
just reset the down values instead of
being that list that can be used in
replace just reset the down values to
some other function that contains inside
it the original down values but has some
wrapper that says you know just just
write no no no
outside the list outside that list
outside the big list there just
outside that list just put in something
like no no but before the big list say
something like
uh you know compiled down values
okay now and then the first then the
comma the first argument would be first
argument of compile down values would be
the compiled code function
or something like it comma and then get
rid of the blank arrow comma and then
the old down values list
so in other words when you say what is
the value of down values the answer is
it's compiled down values
that's a little weird though because i
think that there's there's i can imagine
there being code that kind of
you know sort of relies on the fact that
it's a
list of rules
all right well in that case in that case
you might have do something where
instead of being blank arrow ccf it's
something like
i i don't know exactly what it should be
then
but
but either way the the basic work
something like this
x black y blank
yeah yeah exactly okay
well
yeah ah no sorry
it's this
yes that's fine
yeah it's okay
and i mean maybe there's a
yeah why not i mean and if somebody's
really going to go monkeying inside the
down value list
they'll have you know they'll get what
they get
and it won't be completely crazy
the only thing that will happen is that
that that first
you know entry will shield all the other
entries if you run replace in fact
in reality
the down values will be this
well i don't i mean reality i'm talking
about what
i i know you're talking about what
people see but in reality the down
values have been cleared
except that you've got to store the
original down values somewhere because
people yeah yeah yeah they'll be
yes absolutely yes there can be a store
there will be a store for that
well i mean i've implemented some of
this not not this stuff with down values
and everything okay hold on i mean i
think as a practical matter for safety
the down values should still be there
you can put an internal flag to which
you can immediately check so you never
have to actually look at that list
well i think that okay fine right that's
definitely what i would do what i was
like what color is the font yeah that
might be sensible that might not be
sensible but yes all right absolutely
but but let's just understand the
workflow then
so you type
uh
you know you type in all your
assignments then you say set auto
compile on that function
right okay
might even be set compile i'm not sure
you could just put that somewhere else
that's i mean
i'm just not sure um
either set compile or set auto compile
um maybe several to compile is clear it
depends on the semantics of what when it
auto when it redoes the compilation so
to speak right
okay but so then set auto compile
would mean whenever i type a new
assignment so if i've got a loop and i'm
typing in assignments in the loop i'm
pretty toasted
you see what i'm saying then you
probably want to do
so for example if i have a
i know but what if i have a memoring
function
do you understand what i'm saying i mean
maybe some time we could have something
cleverer for memoing functions we could
recognize this as a memoing function
yeah all right
yeah right but the first thing is yeah
right for now you know you know it won't
i mean it won't be it'll work but it
won't be super efficient and i think if
we had some clever thing for memory i'd
love that that would be fantastic
okay
all right okay but back up here so so to
me this seems pretty sensible is this is
this within what you can implement tom
what we've just discussed i can
implement anything that doesn't violate
the laws of mathematics and physics
um
quite a lot of this i could implement
with the tools i've built you shouldn't
go there
if i've been studying in matter
mathematics it's not clear what that
statement means okay fine right right
well that that's a fascinating
conversation yes right absolutely not
relevant to that not not right
i mean i've been flippant um some of
this involves kernel changes and that
they're kind of slow and ornery and
everything but but i i i've been let's
does everybody else agree that this is a
basically sensible design
yeah i mean i think something like this
sounds like there's going to be some
hairy edges but i think i think yeah i'd
be pretty
okay so andrew has enough of a pattern
compiler that this stuff would run is
that correct
it may not be as efficient as it could
be but it but it will it's yes basically
now these things are let me warn you
these things are dog slow to compile so
well that's the problem has to be found
that's a problem that's the reason you
should make the compiler faster
i mean the compiled patterns you know
when you actually you know run the
compile patterns they're a bit slower in
the evaluator but the real problem is
that
like
i mean i think i think now there's some
mechanism where some parts of them are
sort of pre-compiled and stuff like that
i remember the example i did uh you know
when i first did this i just did match
you know match of blah blah comma
underscore and that took like two
minutes to compile yeah yeah yeah
very slow right right
i mean i think the thing i should really
work on
is making the compiler faster no you
should really work on getting this
workflow
so that we know what we're aiming for
yeah then you know what you're making
i'll i'll put some work into this that
this sounds great i'd like to do okay
all right all right so just so i
understand the actual compiler the
compiled version of the patterns what's
involved in making that faster
so sorry i'm not sure what you mean you
mean what you say the combination time
that two minute compilation time making
that faster mine i'm asking two
questions there's that and there's also
once the patterns are compiled the run
time of the patterns what's involved in
making the runtime of the patterns
faster than the evaluator pattern
matcher yeah i think that they need some
work well first of all is recognizing
being able to recognize that you can do
things like this okay because if you can
do this you're always going to be tons
faster and the other thing is it just
needs sort of study and work and such
like well i mean the original
optimization of the pattern matcher it's
probably still my code from millions of
years ago yeah yeah yeah and it's i mean
i i think with you know andrew worked on
this it was a sort of you know proof of
concept but it but it worked you know
and it it's just matching
remember when i say it's you know when
you say it's slower than the kernel
evaluator it's the same order
yeah as far as i can tell everything
it's like a factor of one and a half
yeah it's something like that so it's
like it's it's very serviceable it's
just that you would if you were writing
code that was all pattern matching you'd
you'd be disappointed when you i don't
that's true andrew because i think that
that i tested it pretty well okay but
when you're
enumerating triple blanks and things
like this does it know how to cut those
those
cases probably not no i i i don't i
don't know but then the colonel doesn't
either
oh yes it does for many yeah it doesn't
well no we can debate the corner
again i think the runtime the runtime
issue i think is not as bad as the
compilation time issue i think the
compilation time issue
thankfully well i'm pretty sure the
reason the compilation time is so slow
is because it does a bunch of stuff with
union types which which right now are
generally really slow but also should
generally be sped up because they'll be
useful for lots of other things yeah
yeah yeah but they're not really slow
but but yes there's there's optimization
the other thing let me point out that
this will make it win is that when
you're processing a whole sequence of
down values that's that's going to be
beneficial and that's that's where the
existing patent matches sort of loses
out i think so can i ask a very
practical question so if i'm using this
stuff
and
i've got a session and i want to compile
things and it's going to take 10 minutes
to do a piece of compilation or 30
minutes or whatever yeah it would be
entirely feasible to save to save your
state out and reload it absolutely yes
that's important well using dump save or
something but no but why do you have to
use dumpster no no no you the whole
point is you've got a serialization of
the final compiled function right we we
have quite nice ways of serializing
these guys out
i know i know i know so i'm just saying
that whatever the serialization is
i'm let me just think about this for a
second
what i'm just trying to understand is
after you have let's see normally you've
got a notebook i'm trying to understand
this workflow
okay do you understand what i'm asking
what i'm asking is this you've got a
notebook you've got a bunch of
assignments usually the workflow is you
re-evaluate those assignments when you
come back into that notebook right right
so what i'm saying but if it's going to
take five years to do that that's not
going to work
right i think dump save is not that
unusual don't even get because that's
already what you do if you have you know
if you have a bunch of data you're
computing or something like that and it
takes 10 minutes well also yes or if
you're creating an api function though
that uses that technology does it not or
doesn't it it uses wxf well if you if
you created an api function from a from
a function that has been compiled how
does it get the compiled version
what do you mean api function i mean a
literal a cloud deployed api function
well you would just send the ccf no no
but no no no let's say all you've got is
test fun and you've you've just given
the code i see i see you're saying that
what would happen is it would
automatically work because it is doing a
save definitions and it's picking up the
down values of test fund is that correct
um
i think that's an important point that
we should
yes so long as safe definitions works i
think it will work i think that will
just work
okay but the case that i'm addressing is
the following you've got a notebook it's
got usually you consider it a zero time
operation to just reevaluate the
initialization cells in the notebook
okay nobody people don't worry about
that time right but if there is
compilation recombilation involved it's
disastrous
the problem is that set comp set auto
compile
doesn't have a savable side effect
right it's just changing kernel state
again i think that's not i don't think
that's that bad because it's how it
already works with data i mean it's it's
there's certain there's certain like
when you make a big notebook where
you're doing long computations there's
some cells like setting definitions that
are like the cheap ones that you just do
every time and they're the expensive
ones that you save out some way or like
well maybe we need to maybe we need to
think through maybe we need a separate
discussion
on this i think if we could
automatically save things in the
notebook somehow so they could be
rehydrated somehow that would be pretty
powerful but it's more convenient right
but so let's have a separate discussion
i mean i can eyes was a great innovation
and what you're saying is some kind of
auto
uh you know auto iconization method um
it's uh you know that it might be nice
to have a general kind of dump save plus
i can eyes
thing
not sure exactly what it would look like
but i mean just something where you
basically you you save you know where
it's just i want to save these
definitions to a notebook
yeah i know i know so let's suppose i
mean you know i mean there's there's
there's import export and there's dump
saved
right let's see i think aubry is pming
here can you aubrey can you
make a note for a separate meeting about
that
okay
all right let's go back here let's go
back to christopher's
no that was very useful but let's go
back to the christmas
all right so i think we were talking
about let's see yeah we were talking
about the
compiler interface
stuff
yeah um
right i mean so basically
i mean so the first thing is that uh i
mean one alternative to this would be to
just there there are sometimes there are
puns where you can kind of say well this
on free function is a little bit like
you know it's a little bit like maybe
you could define something for delete
object and the compiler calls delete
object whenever the thing gets freed or
you know there's some things like this
but honestly i think that's
i don't think that's a great design both
because one there are some cases where
there isn't any clear pun
and two it would be very hard to
document them how are you saying i
understand the functional declaration
how does it attach itself to something
that's just saying on free how does it
say what the data structure okay so so
basically what realistically is going to
happen is that
when when the when the compiler is
trying to create for example in this
case you know the compiler is trying to
create this wrapper that takes you know
it has your function then it will take
the output of your function and convert
it to an expression right when it
compiles that wrapper it's just going to
compile some function
where where this this function is used
in it right yep
so if there's a definition right if
there's a definition for your for your
type that that you know if that function
has a definition for your type then it
will compile if if that function doesn't
have a definition for your type then it
just won't compile i'm sorry i'm totally
confused are you saying there's a single
central function declaration for the
compiler interface of two expression or
there's a separate one of those for each
no sorry so so there'll be a separate
one of these for each struct
right but the point is where will this
actually get used this will actually get
used because somewhere there's a there's
a you know there's a function that's
going to get uh
it's going to get used because somewhere
there's a single function that's going
to get compiled every time that you you
know make a compiled code function and
that single function is basically the
thing that converts you know the output
of your compiled code function into an
expression
and when it and that single function is
just going to be basically a call to
this
right
and and so then if this has a type
signature that matches that usage then
it will work and otherwise it won't if
that makes sense
all right it's the same thing with it's
the same thing with this i mean
basically what the way it will work is
that
right when when an object's ref ref
count goes to zero
right there's some there's some function
that gets run okay and in the middle of
that function you imagine here's the
function that gets run oh my keyboard is
okay yeah here's the uh here's the
function that gets run when some when
when something's recount goes to zero it
says you know oh i'm gonna you know it
takes the it takes the object which has
some type and it's going to say oh i'm
going to do all these low-level c things
to handle that memory
and then by the way i'm going to call
the user supplied function for freeing
this stuff and then i'm going to do some
other stuff cool
there's always there's a default version
of it so we don't understand why object
isn't on top here
why it's on free that's on top of object
rather than it being i mean it's almost
like what you're saying is
you know we have all kinds of crazy
things like format values where it's
format values of f colon equals blah
right and you're basically saying the on
free value of object is blah blah blah
that's that's the that's the syntactic
form that you have here it's kind of
everything is a type it has different
type the type needs to be in there
somewhere
you might have different types you see
it might be polymorphic
so there are many different versions of
obj if it's polymorphic no i realize
that but i'm i'm what i'm asking is i'm
a little bit
confused by why obj isn't on top why it
isn't the case that this is the on free
quotes method of object rather than
saying that it is the on free value of
all you mean you need something like obj
of on free
yeah it's not quite that but i mean
something more like that but that is but
rather that that but not i don't know
whether that's the call i'm saying
what's the assignment
why isn't it that it is a decorator of
obj
you know some
why isn't you you want to be something
like
some something like well okay it is the
thing in charge the alternative to say
on free function of object open close
that would be the the equivalent of the
top level you know with a format or
something like that
right
okay
but the point is that you know and
that's exactly what this is it's just
that you know basically if they're going
to be 10 of these and they're okay all
right so then this is not nice
okay so but if it was called compiler
interface function
if that was its name if it was called
compiler interface function and then the
the the and then there are multiple
kinds of compiler interface functions on
free blah blah blah and they take in
curry in a curried way perhaps they take
obj and then they take the payload which
will be an open close in this case
that makes sense
yeah i'm not sure that there's always a
single object that's like the the thing
right i mean in these three examples
there is a single object that's like the
thing that you're you know like
basically what these are these are
callbacks for when certain events happen
the three events i've listed here are
all you know all have to do with a
single focal object but i don't think
that's necessarily the case so you're
saying that there can be a globally
declared event like on quit or something
that is a sure yeah i mean that would be
a real that would be a reasonable one
that probably should exist yeah on quit
right
um we're on startup and etc
well we have initialized functions um by
the way that's that's right
so what you're saying is
this is
a thing and i don't think it's clear
from the name this is the thing called
by the compiler
i mean
it's like a handler function of some
kind yes
right it's just it's a lot more global
than that
yes
there might be some other better names
and call back in their face
yeah but okay so what this is i'm now
trying to i'm still trying to understand
sometimes it can take
a
so it's a little weird that sometimes it
can take an obj
value in the sort of sub value position
and sometimes it doesn't
what would be could you write what you
think the compiler interface of
onstartup would look like is it compiler
interface of
well the way you would define i mean
really this is not the case to look at
the case look at is where you actually
define the behavior because that's the
only thing anyone should ever do really
correct correct so what you would do is
you'd do something like this you'd say
on startup or something and then you
know you'd have your function why is
that inside function declaration
because this is a function so
this is a function this is the name of
the function
right
i see
that's that's what's happening here too
this is the name of the function but but
usually a declaration does not talk
about actions the declaration is merely
a type specification whereas
exactly but that's only because the
whole point well actually that's not
entirely true i mean the point is is
that
somewhere there's a piece of code like
there's a piece of code that'll get
compiled
you know
but basically the point is is that
there's there's
there's certain cases where where you
know
so so okay let me give you an example
let's say
i define a new
sorry oh it's yes it's going to say
yeah to it java the declaration and
definition come in the same statement
it's c where you declare and define
separately so we're just more javish in
this sense
when you declare the function you
include its definition
i thought in c in modern c and the c
that i always knew
you you would have a you could have it
but i thought that in mumbai you can
declare and define at the same time yes
you can get away with that yeah you
don't have to though
right but okay but then the point is let
me give you an example suppose i define
a new a new type you know a new object
and i'd like to be able to to define how
to cast between that object and some
other objects right yes the way you do
that is you say function declaration i'm
defining a new cast and i give it some
type
right and i give it some type that's
that's based on my
that that uses my new type and then i
give it a definition right and now if
the types align just like defining a new
down value then this is what it will
call
i found a declaration okay a declaration
contains actual code to run is that true
it is it's there yeah yes there there'd
be actual code here right
right so the point is this is exactly
the same thing right so just as in this
case in this case basically what's
happening is you're saying anytime
someone calls cast right if they happen
to call cast on my new type
then then this is a definition to use
this is exactly the same thing this is
saying if someone you know if someone is
ever happening to compile a piece of
code that needs to convert my type to an
expression then this is the code yeah
but is function declaration like an
assignment or is it something that's
that's symbolic that's inside some other
outer uh think of it as an assignment
think of it as an assignment
yeah so it happens at the time you type
it
well it happens when you put it into
controller environment depend too
exactly but i mean you know it is itself
inert but it'll almost always appear in
a position where you know it's it's
being put into action
okay okay but it its name
suggests inertness and it is in fact
inert because it has to be hydrated it
has to be activated by something
absolutely there are potential functions
when you write it polymorphically
especially it's a potential function not
not a concrete function
the is is okay
okay so people and will typically have
code that has a bunch of function
declarations and then they'll have a
single compiler environment append too
is that right yes yes yes correct
okay all right okay
well this seems reasonable i i agree
that your compiler interface name is
i think it's right to have a single name
and a bunch of string
cases there
i can't think of an obviously better
name immediately yeah i mean i think
callback is honestly a little bit better
than interface
but it's still really totally clear
i mean i i think a third would be even
better but i think i mean i just think
that
interface is a little bit generic but
yeah yes but i'm concerned that you're
going to end up wanting some
thing okay so the the issue is here
uh
well what this is is it's a
function to be called by the compiler
upon upon an event
see this seems more like in this case
it's an object interface
versus
and i mean obviously some other things
like
on startup or a compiler interface or or
a um well
well are you arguing andrew that there
are two different categories of things
yeah yeah if you you know if you want to
just use a big generic name like
compiler interface it's not the worst
thing in the world but these are a
little more specific
i mean there are different categories of
these kinds of interfaces so we might
have more specific names for them
but that's in the ontology of the string
that's in the payload of things yeah i
mean
i have no objection to a compiler
interface i'm just pointing that out
right okay
we are officially out of time here but
what was can you give us a preview
of um yeah okay well there's there's
this stuff about expressions which we've
talked mentioned last time but still
haven't gotten too there's this stuff
about the potential for this other
function that's a little light create
data structure but a little bit
different
there's the stuff about
uh
uh basically dealing with
dangerous you know heap allocations in a
way that isn't dangerous
um and then the new stuff is
this one is a quick one basically
they're
[Music]
basically it's a function or a symbol or
something
for getting you the return type of the
current function which is something you
actually need because you can have type
signatures like like this where
basically the return type is not
determined by the input types determined
by what you said you don't know what to
do
right so you need to be able to query
that but what is this is just automatic
as the return type
no no so the issue is the issue is that
i'm writing a function and you know
let's say it takes no arguments and
uh you know and it does whatever it does
but but then the point is is that this
function can have
depending on what eats this function it
can have different types so for example
i might have this one is not a great
example but i might have multiple
definitions of range so that range
depending on what eats it it could
either generate a list vector or a
packed array right because maybe the
thing that eats it only eats packed
arrays and so that's what it should
return but maybe it only eats list
vectors
and then so that's what it returns sorry
try this again i'm not understanding
okay when i call range so so
suppose i you know okay let's say i have
two versions of range one version that
returns a packed array one version of
their terms a list vector you know some
other list-like thing right these are
both reasonable type declarations for
range
so so how would i do that well i'm gonna
have two definitions i'm gonna have let
me i'll have function declaration of
range comma you know typed
this and then you know and then some
definition right so let's say this is
the the first this is the first one so
it takes a uh you know the length
and and and uh you know and then uh
well uh actually sorry this this is not
the
well okay yeah yeah they actually did
this example
sorry this example doesn't doesn't
doesn't quite work well because it can't
be i can't write like
i can't it's hard to write with type for
all in this case
um
let me do it a
different well okay basically that the
case is that
look i'm gonna omit the type here for a
second but just basically
know that we're going to have something
goes to a packed array and i'm going to
have another declaration where it's
something that you use is a bit cast put
a void handle in there or opaque pointer
and then you do it right okay so
basically the point is is that you can
have functions okay here's an example
that's that's that that's less intuitive
but um
but but actually works so two-pointer
uh
you know returns a pointer takes no arg
you know if you if you give it zero
arguments if you just do two points or
open close it returns a pointer
to a t
right but there's no t in the inputs
so how does it know what the t is the
answer is it knows that by what eats it
right so if i call two pointer on its
own it's gonna be it's gonna be confused
right like it's gonna say you know i i
can't figure out the type of this but if
i say x equals two pointer and then i
say call my you know
uh let's say there's some c function i
say you know library function of
you know
who knows you know i'm calling some c
function right i feed it x
then because it knows the type of this
function it knows that well in the first
argument i'm going to take a pointer to
an integer 64.
and so it now you know
and so so you you know that that's how
this this works
so the point is that in the source of
this function if i need to know what
what is this t going to be bound to mean
what type am i actually returning
i can't figure that out from the inputs
i can only figure it out by knowing what
the output type is going to be
but i mean so you're saying it's at run
time you cut you can't figure out the
type except at run time no compile time
okay but you can't figure it out
statically when you're writing the code
you can only figure it out correct you
can always
figure when that function is used
yeah you can only figure out by the
context
right and so the point is is that you
know you can tell based on what the
input arguments are but you can also
there's also cases where you can only
tell based on what the type of the
output is which might not be purely
based on what the input types are
because why because why isn't it only
based on the input it's basically
because you can have you can have a
definition you can have two versions of
range one that returns a list vector and
one that returns a packed array
and and it's sort of uh
overloading on the other which
right so why isn't this sort of
sliding into dependent types
or am i wrong i don't think this has
anything to do with dependent types
but this the type depends on
something
the dependency type is more about
run time i mean
in this case it's more it's more
it's more just that it's it's when you
compile it you know the it means it
depends on the context of where the
function is called right which is
already the case in the sense that you
know you for if you have a polymorphic
function which is where the supplies
then you already need to know the
context of what the input types are and
now this is just they're saying well
then you also need to know the context
of what the output type is
because the point is unlike in evaluated
code where you can only overload in the
inputs here you can also overload the
outputs
because the type inferencer is going to
you know do it
right so you needed
a declaration for the type that is only
to be determined that is to be
automatically determined at compile time
right i mean so this is basically just
you need to somehow be able to to ask
hey what what's my return type going to
be
right so that's that's what this is
so for example you'd say uh
you know
right i see so it's like it's like in c
you might have a size of for example
that is that is being that is a sort of
pseudo macro thing applied to types
that resolves i don't even know when
size of resolves
does that make any sense i think that's
that compiles time when when the time is
i know it's a compile time but i just
don't know what you could do there is a
size of you know you could do size of
return yeah there's different that's a
different well okay yeah sure i mean
that would be something that well you
could do prints you could do print uh i
don't know
no but what you're saying is that we
will have also a size of thing that is
resolvable at compile time yeah we have
yeah we already see it's like a mac okay
here's an idea for a simple example so
suppose you want to write accumulate as
opposed to range and you could have a
packed array which is
you know real or a packed array which is
complex
and what you want to do is you want to
you want to start with something say
call a variable sum you want to say sum
equals 0 but you want that 0 to either
be complex or real and that's where you
would use the doll return type yeah
that's a good example rob that's that's
a good example yeah
so you would do something like sum
equals you know typed of zero of element
type of dollar you know returned
precisely yeah yeah that that would be
good
down our livestream is suggesting dollar
function signature
as a
it's not the
signature it's just that it's just the
return type
yeah i'm a little confused by
unfortunately we have run out of time
here
yeah okay so the last the last thing
which is a big one is sort of talking
about compiler-backed packlets
which is related to some of the down
valley compilation stuff actually but
but basically this is about if you want
to write a paclet that
well
the two different cases but i mean if
you want to write a packet that either
is a top level thing that relies on
compiled code or you want a packet that
extends you know the compiler
then these are the
there's a third case actually
christopher which is building there's
more cases there's building a library
from compiled code in the paclets
and there's always i mean that's
i consider that the first one but but
yeah
um
let's continue we probably should try to
get a two-hour slot if we can at least
hour and a half maybe thursday hour and
a half let's let's have frequent shorter
meetings are better than infrequent long
meetings well
okay except that it takes me a little
while to get my you know it's like the
world state and then you'll you'll keep
warmed up you see so all right well okay
let's try and plan for thursday
whatever right
right
okay well a lot of interesting stuff um
and i mean we're just in the middle here
so let's plan to continue this as soon
as we can
okay all right thanks